Самохідна гаубиця M109L,
одна з переданих Україні Італією, працює у Донецькій області.
22-річний артилерист із позивним "Шпак"
розповідає: цілять по піхоті й артилерії противника.
Складні моменти - це щільність роботи.
Ми працюємо практично кожен день.
Підтримуємо нашу піхоту.
Це вимотує.
На Донеччині й Запоріжжі ЗСУ поступово рухаються вперед.
Є просування на таврійському напрямку,
а також на південь від Бахмута.
На думку ексдиректора ЦРУ Девіда Петреуса,
успіхи стали можливими завдяки тому,
що ЗСУ змінили тактику.
Просування було неможливим через глибину мінних полів,
відсутність переваги в повітрі і брак броньованої
штурмової техніки, яку, скажімо,
США використали б у такій ситуації.
Українці застосовують малі групи піхоти
по 10 людей, які рухаються від посадки до посадки,
промацуючи шлях через мінні поля,
шукаючи шляхи обходу, захищаючи зайняті позиції
і займаючи наступну посадку, наступний будинок.
Удари по російському флоту, такі як ураження
корабля й підводного човна в Севастополі в ніч на 13 вересня,
теж вважаються наступальними діями.
Командувач Повітряних сил ЗСУ натякнув
на роботу української авіації з допомогою
західних далекобійних ракет Storm Shadow.
Якщо США нададуть Україні і свої далекобійні ракети ATACMS,
таких ударів може бути більше.
На думку американських посадовців,
ATACMS можуть стати вирішальними для контрнаступу.
Надані США касетні боєприпаси
також сприяли просуванню ЗСУ,
зокрема, в районі Роботиного.
Такі снаряди розкидають малі бомби
і вражають живу силу й техніку
противника на відкритій місцевості.
За повідомленнями ЗМІ, США можуть
надіслати Україні ракети ще більшої
дальності з касетними бомбами.
У нас також є касетні боєприпаси,
які можуть застосовуватися системами HIMARS,
які долітатимуть значно далі.
Варто було б надавати і їх теж,
адже вони дадуть змогу вражати
російські війська значно далі від лінії фронту.
Вони ефективні і їх варто використовувати.
Водночас західні аналітики
прогнозують: з кінця жовтня погода
почне погіршуватися, тож
наступальні операції сповільняться.
І в Україні, і на Заході стримані в
оцінках того, що ЗСУ зможуть
досягти за цей час.
Перед українськими військовими
стоїть дуже складне завдання,
складніше за будь-що, що я міг би
згадати з часів Другої світової війни,
і набагато складніше, ніж у двох
війнах, в яких я мав честь бути командувачем.
Думаю, українці чудово справляються,
і є підстави очікувати, що вони
зможуть продовжувати повільний,
але невпинний прогрес, розширюючи
прорив, особливо довкола Роботиного,
просуваючись через другу й третю
лінії російської оборони.
На думку очільника ГУР Кирила
Буданова, холоди й бездоріжжя
не вплинуть на контрнаступ.
Адже головну роль на полі бою грає
не важка бронетехніка.
Велика насиченість переносними протитанковими
комплексами, іншими одноразовими
особливо протитанковими засобами та дронами-камікадзе
дуже знизила ефективність застосування
будь-якої бронетанкової техніки.
Тому в більшості, на жаль, наш наступ
те що називається йде "на ногах".
Президент Зеленський в інтерв'ю CNN заявив,
що після чотирьох місяців важкого наступу
деяка обіцяна Заходом зброя усе ще "в дорозі".
З огляду на це експерти вважають
нинішнє просування ЗСУ значним успіхом.
Але все частіше мова йде про те,
що наступний ривок доведеться робити навесні.
Я вважаю, що ЗСУ не зможуть
досягти Азовського моря цього року.
Очевидно, що війна триватиме.
Черговий український наступ скоріш
за все почнеться навесні наступного року,
коли вже будуть F-16, що буде
великою перевагою, адже нині одним
з найбільш слабких місць є
відсутність будь-якої переваги в повітрі,
будь-якого захисту в повітрі для
механізованих бригад, які
перебувають на фронті.
В України будуть F-16, танки М1 Abrams,
нові поставки озброєнь протягом зими.
Краще було б прорватися зараз
і позбавити Росію можливості
підтримувати логістику й поставки,
які можуть тривати взимку.
Якщо це не вдасться зробити цієї осені,
хоча я думаю, що може вдатися,
то українські військові досягнуть
цього наступної весни і в них буде
більше зброї, за допомогою якої
можна зробити прорив.
З околиць Бахмута, де більше року
тривають бої, евакуюють поранених.
З червня українські військові звільнили
49 квадратних кілометрів у цьому регіоні.
Кожен метр має свою ціну.
Зараз відбувається штурм.
І ми все зробили на відмінно.
Це добре. Трошки в нас поранених,
але нічого. Без цього ніяк.
За словами експертів, через специфічний
клімат на сході України дощі
й морози не будуть перепоною для наступальних дій.
Росія активізувала свій наступ
на Бахмут саме в грудні торік.
Нині ініціатива в руках ЗСУ.